all right I'm very excited today we are
at Politico we have a packed room I
don't even have to make that up we
actually have a standing-room-only room
at poletik on i am here with michael
steele he is the former head of the
Republican Party can I say that is that
the official you were the head of the
Republican National Committee but
Republican Committee a head of the party
the guy with the biggest target on his
back yeah yeah exactly he is also the
former lieutenant governor of Maryland
and are you still currently at MSNBC I
am I'm a generalist over at MSNBC so one
of a very small group of conservative
voices oh yeah do they let you guys in
over there who's like we have to come in
the back we get to come I get I get to
come in and and folks are very nice it's
really good I get water and every once
in a while I get to you know say hi to
people so it's good yeah wait who else
are the conservatives over there Joe
Scarborough yeah and me yeah all right
good very good very good okay so there's
a ton I want to talk to you about
including cable news so we'll save some
of that data later so let's just start
first because you are a Republican yeah
according to my notes they gave me here
you are black is that correct today yes
yeah well you know I worked I've been
working on the tan yeah and I've gotten
really good at it so yeah yeah all right
so a black Republican that was what a
party I know imagine they exist explain
that today whether it's it's called
history and a lot of folks really don't
appreciate the the very unique history
between Republican the Republican Party
and the black community it is our
political home it is where we first
emerged in this country politically and
certainly you know Lincoln and the
abolitionists and and in fact the party
was born out of a fight between
abolitionists and Whigs over the issue
of slavery and the thankfully the
abolitionists won and
the Republican Party was essentially
formed Frederick Douglass notable
african-american slave then free man was
very much a part of helping to build
this party so we've got this very unique
history and as a young a young kid of
seventeen looking at getting involved
politically for the first time I was
like you know my mom who is a Roosevelt
Democrat you know my family very very
much Democrats and my mother raised me
to say hey you know go out there and
discover and and decide for yourself
don't let our party affiliation or what
we're doing influence you just because
we're Democrats and your aunts a
Democrat and your grandmother's a
Democrat and your grandfather's Democrat
and your cousins are Democrats ya know
no pressure so I did I went out and I
did the study and I realized that what
this is our home this is the political
home for the party Ronald Reagan was
running for president in 76 at that time
was my first election to vote in and he
sounded a lot like my mom in terms of
how my mother talked to me about me you
know as a young man in this country and
you know having opportunities taking
advantages of opportunities so it
connected it resonated and you know what
and told mommy
you know I've registered as a Republican
and she looked at me she said Lord what
so why'd you do that well you know
that's all been good yes so that's a lot
of the history but I think I'm gonna
guess that a lot of the people here
would say well this doesn't seem to be
the party know people now it's not well
and I hate playing identity politics
yeah I don't want to get into that
because that's that's a slippery slope
on so many levels or you know for both
parties actually who've really screwed
up our politics with identity politics
but and we can have that discussion but
I think there is a legitimacy to the to
the point that we have I think failed
over the last 50 years to appreciate
that history and I started with a
history because to me it is an important
place to start because it you then you
then follow that into the fight that
would later come
on civil rights and the Republican
leaders who themselves conservatives at
that time like their their forefathers
politically the abolitionists were were
stewards of this ideal in the Senate in
the house and Johnson Lyndon Johnson
knew that and yet a political decision
was made for crass political gain and
and that was to that national politics
the idea of controlling the presidency
or winning elections for Congress meant
more than other things and we walked
away we walked away from the black
community and and I think we are still
paying the price for that yeah so I
think that's a good set up for for the
first part here which what does being a
Republican in 2015 in America right now
with our system is so screwed up so
wacky I feel like people don't even know
what it right they don't even to you
they've lost meaning because it's all
gotten conflated into other labels and
and so you know whether it's Tea Party
is conservative or is this and I just
make the case that at the end of the day
there there's a thread of value or
values or principles ideals that you
ascribe to whether it is your view on
the role of government in the lives of
the American people historically
Republicans have not been
anti-government they have been for
limited government they think government
is a legitimate it is a legitimate
entity it has a legitimate purpose
though a limited purpose whether that
thread or idea centers around how you
view the culture in other words that you
know morality and concerns for the
unborn or whatever the the issues may be
that that's a part of that narrative so
there there are broader there broader
strokes that have been used or sort of
stripped down in a way that gets us into
this crass political discussion about
I'm right you're wrong on an issue and
that that's never that's never really
the
all and I think the I kind of sum it up
this way that I I look at the party and
I certainly saw this as a county
chairman and as national chairman and a
state chairman that even in a state like
Maryland
I had Western Maryland which was very
conservative I had where I lived in
Prince George's in the Beltway area
which was very liberal you had Southern
Maryland which was conservative but
trending purple you had you know so you
have this these different dynamics and
you have to kind of lead in that you got
to govern in that and you realize that
politics is really about the art of the
possible it's not about the art of the
angry or scoring points or gaining
advantage it really is about how do I
take all of these disparate parts and
different viewpoints and and figure out
how to affect a positive change or
policy a positive change on a set of you
know ideas right and that that's gotten
lost today and it's hard and you're
seeing this play out right now in the
GOP this this internecine struggle over
identity who we are what we believe and
why we value that yeah so to the to the
point of what the party actually stands
for I'm always amazed by the fact that
if you take two like hot-button issues
that are that are clearly Democrat
pocket issues gay rights and legalizing
marijuana those are Democrat issues
therefore you know basically for
legalizing weed basically for gay rights
but it seems to me a true Republican
that would want small government well
you wouldn't care what someone does in
their bedroom whether it's having sex
with someone of the same sex or whether
smoking weed right well shouldn't that
be a Republican issue well I would argue
that it probably once was I mean that
remember that the GOP also has as a part
of its roots a libertarian threat a very
strong libertarian threat
I've always been amused that those who
who would argue about the limited role
of government on one issue but then
argue for the expansion of government on
another issue right so that that's so so
that being authentically consistent for
me is very important is it's like when
people
ask me about my views on life and and I
tell them I said well I'm pro-life I'm
very much pro-life and a lot of dentists
to come from how I was raised it comes
to my faith tradition and how I've been
taught and and come to believe in value
in life so when it comes to the death
penalty
I'm against it and I always get well how
can you be against a death penalty
well because I'm pro-life right you know
so you've got to be consistent from
beginning to the end and that's not what
we see happening yeah do you can you
think of a politician off the top your
head that's consistent actually that
really is is governing or a real setup I
can't think anybody I mean can you think
anyone can any of you think of anyone
anyone that's governing no because
they're not allowed to they're not
allowed to do it because the the the
tensions inside both caucus of cocci are
are such that latin coming back is is so
so intense that look I grew up in DC and
so I the the nation's capital has been
in my backyard forever and so I remember
Washington when it was fun to be in
Washington and you could go when I was a
kid I used to go sit on the Capitol
Steps at 11 o'clock when I was in high
school with my buddies we grabbed a
liter of coke and a bag ship the soda
the soda I'm just seeing what principals
your guide yes yes yes yes I see I threw
in liter of coke as I used to say I used
to grab some coke and a bag of chips
look at me I'm like no soda okay okay
just so you know we was sitting but we
would sit on the step so you hang out
with the Capitol Police and all so and
you see members coming back in a talk
you go to restaurants in town and you
could see a table where you know a
conservative or a Democrat a Republican
they weren't conservative liberal there
was a Republican and Democrat would be
off talking policy or just shooting the
breeze you don't see that now
they don't they don't mix they don't
talk they don't integrate they don't
want to be a part of this they don't
bring their families here they go back
to the districts which they should do
but there's this disconnect and the
consequence of that is what we see now
there there is no reason for me to work
with you
remember when I was chairman and we were
doing getting ready for the 2010
election of course you're going out
you're meeting candidates and you're
sort of interviewing them to see who you
want to line up and support and who yeah
and not so much and I met this one
candidate and we got into a nice
conversation you know solid rock real
conservative and these company is fire
and brimstone ready to come to
Washington and so we were talking and
and I said something about well you know
we get to DC you know cuz at that time
the Dems were still in charge I said you
know one of the real interesting
challenges is gonna be working with with
the the leadership on the other side and
working with Democrats I'm not doing
that I say excuse me doing that I said
why are you coming to Washington he said
I'm coming here to work with Democrats
that's the attitude and that's weekend
deficit and that's that's it's a lot of
things it's not just Tea Party a lot of
people put a lot of pressure on Tea
Party and and the Tea Party came into
being on my watch so I know very well
what was the the essence of that in that
time but what people don't recognize is
that movement such as it is that energy
started way before 2009 this goes back
to 2004 this goes back to 2002 big
government republicanism the spending on
the war the Terri Schiavo case remember
the Terri Schiavo case when the
Republicans called the Senate back into
session to pass a bill to prevent this
family from the making decision about
this poor woman who was in a coma again
these are the people they want
government so on the one hand you say
you know government it should be out of
the way but then the other you're gonna
call Congress into session to pass a
bill to tell someone what they can't do
in this instance that's that's the
conundrum that the parties put itself